>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington D.C.
>> Karen Jaffe: Ok welcome
and we thank several of you
who got here very early and on time.
So I'd like to introduce first the
participants in the program, the ???
Charter School.
You want to raise your hand;
everyone knows who you are.
Or public school in Washington
D.C. raise your hands.
And how about Oak view and Fairfax
Virginia; they came the farthest.
Welcome to the young reader
center at the library of Congress.
Has anyone been to the
Library of Congress before?
Anybody raise your hand.
This is your first time, well,
we've very happy to have you
and we hope you come
back again to the library
and to the young reader
center, which is where you are.
We are very very excited this
morning to have a special guest
who came the farthest
from Hollywood California.
Octavia Spencer is a very famous
actress in film and television,
but she's also an author.
And she's written a book
Randi Rodes Ninja Detective,
the case of the time capsule bandit.
And she's here today to
talk to you about her book.
How it came about and to see if you
have any questions about the book
and about her interest in
children and literature.
So here she is, Octavia Spencer.
>> Octavia Spencer:
That would be me.
[ Applause ]
>> Thank you all.
Thank you.
So I like to do, I get
paid to talk as a living,
so I like to do a little bit of
talking and a lot of interacting
because you guys have come from far
and wide; some of you from very far.
I'd like to talk to
you a little bit.
Is that ok if I do a
little bit of talking
and then you guys can
ask me questions?
What?
>> Yes
>> Octavia Spencer:
Ok, here's the rule.
If you when you when we get to
that part of question and answer,
since I don't know your name, say
your name and then ask you question,
but if somebody does this, I want to
know hum, what are we going to do?
We're going to say no.
Ok? So that they think of it, right?
Because we want the person from
the back, we want you to be able
to hear what this person says and
we want them to hear what you say.
Is that cool?
>> Yes
>> Octavia Spencer: Alright,
what do you want to know?
My book, I was, I know
it's hard to believe now,
but I was actually
your age some time ago.
And I really enjoy going to school
but I had a problem with reading.
And my grades weren't very good,
but my teachers knew that I was,
that I could handle the work
they really believed in me
and I didn't understand why
things were the way they were;
as far as studying goes.
I didn't understand why had such a
hard time, so I had to study harder
than most just to be with the class,
just to be where we were in class,
just to be on the same level
as the other kids in my class.
How many of you know,
have heard of dyslexia?
Yes, that's I like, I don't like
to call it a learning disability,
I like to call it a challenge
because disability means
that you're not able, you disabled,
you can't do and I like and turn
that around and say, well I
might it might take me longer,
but I can get there.
And I eventually did
because I wrote a book.
Took me a long time
to write that book
and I'll you why I wrote the
type of book that I wrote.
Randi Rhodes Ninja Detectives;
first of all I wanted
to me a ninja [Laughter]
believe it or not.
And but you know Ninja jujitsu is
not something that they're going
to teach a little girl in Alabama.
So anything karate, karate',
actually, or Taekwondo
or anything involving martial arts;
I just you know like most kids,
six or seven, I just
said, its Ninja.
They're all Ninja's.
So I know that Ninja Jujitsu is
very different from Taekwondo,
but in the world of
my characters one
of the little boys really
wants, you know, be a Ninja.
And I also like mysteries and the
one thing that helped me learn
that helped me stay in
engage in my studies,
believe it or not, were mysteries.
And because you know, what
I found is with a mystery,
you're always trying to figure
out what happened right?
You're always trying to
figure out who did what right?
So I would read my mystery books
and that would help me in my studies
because it made me want
to ask those questions.
Remember I said there
are no dumb questions,
not knowing the answer
is the dumb part right.
So you know, if you're
respectful about wanting
to know it's always a good thing to
have a question in your heart right?
If you didn't know now, now you do.
Ok, so I decided to write a book
about kids, who solved mysteries;
who look a lot like some
of you in this room.
Because it helped me.
Mysteries helped me.
And so if any of you guys
have a learning challenge,
not a learning disability, hopefully
this story will be engaging enough
to keep you interested.
And to keep you reading, to
keep you wanting to know more.
The other thing is
because I am a detective
at heart, I like to know things.
I told you that.
And since I like to know things, I
thought you'd like to know things.
Right? Right?
>> Yes
>> Octavia Spencer: Oh, maybe not.
Well see my detectives show,
teach you how to detect.
Like let see they teach you how
to make the cast of a foot print,
you know, you know what that is?
If you walk outside in the dirt
and you leave your foot print my
detectives actually teach you how
to do that in the back of this book.
So but you got to read the book to
get, you can't just open the back
of it and learn how to do that.
And my detectives, how many
of you guys like ice cream?
Ah, yeah, I thought you might.
One of the characters in the
book owns an ice cream parlor.
And my detectives actually
don't teach you how to do that,
but there is a five minute recipe
to ice cream; how to make ice cream
in the back of this book.
It's all that stuff that I like to
do and I figured if I like to do it,
they'd like to do it right?
>> Yes
>> Octavia Spencer: And like right
here I'm putting my finger on this,
can you guys see where my finger is?
Can you see my finger print?
>> No.
>> Octavia Spencer: No you can't.
But I teach you how to get that
off, how to lift the finger print.
Ah, you didn't know that did you?
Yes, but you got to read this book.
So I'm glad you guys are taking
this home and meeting my kids.
Did I just spill the beans?
I think I did.
I spilled beans.
Ah I spilled the beans.
But Randy, DC and Pudge are my kids.
And they've been with me
for a long, long time.
And I, I really love to read.
It's still hard for me; still
takes me a long time to read a book
and the minute I look at a book
and see it's like that thick,
I just get so depressed because I
hope it's going to be a good one.
If it's not a good book
that's that thick it's like,
oh, the time I've wasted.
But here's the good news.
I've not read a book that that's
thick that hasn't been good.
So if you pick up a book and it's
that thick and you're like oh,
there's so many other things
that I'd rather be doing
than reading this book;
get to the end of it
and if you didn't like it, it's ok.
But if you did like it
will make seeing a book
that thick again not
so daunting, right?
You won't look at that
book and go it's too thick.
I used to do that.
I still do, not going
to, not going to kid you.
But I actually haven't
found one that's been bad
so they don't scare me as much.
Who did that?
Jacob, is that you
Jacob, my dear Jacob.
So why don't we open this up and you
guys since we have like a good hour,
you can ask me questions
and I can answer them
and then we can learn a
little bit about each other.
Is that ok?
>> Yes
>> Octavia Spencer:
Alright, I like you guys.
Ok, let's start.
Yes what's your name?
Deon.
>> [Inaudible]
>> Octavia Spencer:
Ok, I spill the beans.
I don't know if you knew, but
you probably might be, maybe,
possibly, each getting a book.
[Laughing] And because you all
showed up to say hey to me today.
I wrote my name in this book
so you wouldn't throw it away.
[ Applause ]
>> Octavia Spencer: Ok?
I signed them all for you so
you won't throw them away.
Because if it's not signed, like
uh, I'm going to throw it away,
I don't know, I don't
know about that book.
Who's next with the question?
Yes ma'am, you've got to,
don't be shy; you looked away
that means you're going to be shy.
What's your name?
>> Aida
>> Octavia Spencer: Aida,
what's your question honey?
>> My question is, what was
it like acting in the help?
>> Octavia Spencer: What was
How many of you even
have heard of the help?
>> I've seen it.
>> Octavia Spencer:
You've seen it, well.
That she says looking
directly at me.
Well I'll tell you this Aida,
movies, that's my job acting.
And sometimes the subject matter is
fun, but what those women had to do
and during that time
period in history,
for women of color,
wasn't a fun time.
So no it was not fun because I had
to go places that I never had to go.
That I know that my grandmother
had to go emotionally,
so it wasn't a fun thing to do.
But I had fun meeting new
friends and making new friends
and because we did
something special,
they're all still very close to me.
And my life has been forever
enhanced because of the help.
Did I answer your question?
Ok, yes, oh, what's your name?
Who? What's your name?
Steven, ok.
>> How many books have you made?
>> Octavia Spencer: I just
turned in my second book Steven.
So after you read this one, get
ready for the second one ok?
[ Applause ]
>> Octavia Spencer: Ok, we've
got to get someone else sweetie.
Anybody else back there,
ok what's your name?
>> Nadia
>> Octavia Spencer:
Nadia very nice Nadia.
Did you guys here that?
Nadia, alright Nadia.
>> How many movies were you in?
>> Octavia Spencer: Oh how many
movies, oh I don't know sweetie
because there were some we
just don't count anymore.
About a hundred I guess.
Well, don't be too impressed guys,
don't be too impressed because, ok,
let's describe this
as a movie set right?
I've always had something
to say in a movie, always,
but sometimes that something
to say would be like,
how many books have you written?
Two, but you have to count
that as a movie that you're in.
We did a lot of those types of
projects, about a hundred movies;
about a hundred TV
shows, I'm thinking.
I don't really know.
Yes, what's your name?
>> John
>> Octavia Spencer: John.
>> Have you ever been in a cartoon?
>> Octavia Spencer: I
have been in a cartoon
and I'm working on one right now.
Whew [Laughter].
Ah, cartoon; let's see, oh yeah,
it's one that you wouldn't
have been able watch though.
Wait, no yeah, the family guy,
not the family guy, family dad,
somebody like that; American Dad.
[ Laughter ]
>> Octavia Spencer: Yeah American
Dad, but I'm actually working
on a movie right now called Boo,
and it is really, really fun;
the bureau of other
worldly operations.
And it's basically FBI ghost.
It's pretty fun.
Yes ma'am.
Name?
>> Isabella
>> Octavia Spencer: Isabella.
>> Where are you from?
>> Octavia Spencer: Where am I from?
That's a very good question.
Well I'm from London Isabella.
No, I'm from Montgomery Alabama,
which is, oh I was about to say,
I thought I was in Atlanta.
I was just in Atlanta working so
my brain, which is right next door,
it is not right next
door to where we are.
I am from Montgomery Alabama.
Do you know it?
>> Yes
>> Octavia Spencer: You've heard
of it, you've never been there?
Ok, where are you from?
>> D.C.
>> Octavia Spencer: D.C., I like
D.C. Someone we haven't, yes ma'am.
>> Lyla
>> Octavia Spencer: Lyla.
>> Ok, would you let me
co-write in one of your books?
>> Octavia Spencer: She asked me
if I would let her
co-write in one of my books.
Can I tell you what you can do?
You can write your own book.
You don't need to co-write
with anybody.
You can write your own book.
The world is your oyster.
And right now, you put down
whatever, there's no right or wrong.
I tell you what though, you write it
and send it to me and I'll read it.
>> Ok.
>> Octavia Spencer: Is that a deal?
We'll make sure you get
Paul's email address, alright?
Now don't, don't make
me check in and say
when am I going to get pages.
I will stay on you now.
Someone else, we've got the same
people who want to ask questions.
You guys just bored of me already?
Usually takes about two hours
before people become bored.
Yes honey, what's your name?
>> Jaaki
>> Octavia Spencer:
Jaaki, say that again?
>> Have you written any poems?
>> Octavia Spencer: Have
I written any poems?
Yes I have.
Have you? Ok, that, why
did you ask me that?
Do you like poems?
>> Yes
>> Octavia Spencer:
What's your favorite poem?
Do you know one right
now that you can say?
That have really good words in it.
I'm making you nervous
right now, ok.
But I have written poems.
You can write poems too.
Ok, next to you.
Oh, what was that name?
>> Alfonzo.
>> Octavia Spencer: Alfonzo.
>> Have you ever, like
>> Octavia Spencer:
What is Alfonzo doing?
No. Ok Alfonzo.
You've got to speak up.
>> Have you ever learned anything
that was too easy in school?
>> Octavia Spencer: Have
I ever learned anything
that was too easy in school?
Yeah, I have learned some
things that were too easy
and then what happens is you sit
there and your mind starts wondering
because it's too easy
right, until test day;
when you should have been paying
attention because you knew it
at the time and then when test
day happens, you forgot the steps
to show your work and problems.
Sometimes things are
going to be easier
or sometimes they're
going to be a challenge.
But yeah, I have, I can say yeah.
I have, have you?
Yeah, I thought you were smart guy.
That's a good thing thought;
that's a very good thing.
Anybody else who hasn't
asked a question yet?
Yes ma'am right here.
>> My names Shamia.
Which movie have you
started in a month?
>> Octavia Spencer: Which movie have
I started; that hasn't happened yet.
I'm about to be on
a television show.
I've never done TV
full time so it's going
to be very different
and excited about it.
But I don't know, that's my job.
It seems very, very glamorous
because it's movies and television.
But I'm going to let you
guys in on a little secret.
We wake up really, really early and
we go to bed really, really late.
You travel a lot and you
don't get to see your families
as much as you'd like to.
And sometimes I have a problem
being on stage and seeing people,
and when I found out
that we were going
to be taping this I got
real nervous, oh gosh.
So, but it's my job and oop,
what's going on over here?
What's going, when I'm
talking you listen, right?
We don't do that, ok?
So that's just what I do.
It may seem like it's
really, really glamorous
because you guys see the parts where
we're, you know, in pretty dresses
and people taking pictures
in magazines.
That part is really
the least fun for me.
The, you know, pictures in
the magazines and all of that.
That's not the fun part.
But I really love what I do,
but you should also know the
down side of it, too, you know.
It's like, that's that, is
that ok, I mean you know.
You guys want to know
the truth right?
>> Yes
>> Octavia Spencer:
Good, good I like that.
Yes Sir.
>> Deon, which part do
you play in American Dad?
>> Octavia Spencer: I
don't know, it was a nurse
or somebody in American Dad.
Now what do you, I
don't think that show,
I don't think you guys can
be watching American Dad.
>> Octavia Spencer: That's not a,
that's not a good show
for I don't think.
Or maybe I'm thinking
of the wrong thing.
This boo movie is a perfect
movie for you to watch.
Anybody else, I'm going to
come back to you sweetie,
I want to give people who
haven't had a chance, yes ma'am.
>> Lauren,
>> Octavia Spencer:
What's your name hun?
Ah!
>> Laura, what month
year [Inaudible]
>> Octavia Spencer: What year, ok
I well that's a two part answer.
We filmed it in twenty ten and
it came out in twenty eleven.
Alright, back row, yes ma'am.
Ok, you're going to
go first in the yellow
and then you'll go after her ok?
>> My name is Irania.
>> Octavia Spencer:
What's your name?
>> Irania.
>> Octavia Spencer: Ivanaia?
[ Multiple People Speaking ]
>> Irania.
>> Octavia Spencer: Ok, Irania?
Ok.
>> What made you start acting?
>> Octavia Spencer: What
made me start acting?
Well I was a ham as a child.
No, I'm just, these jokes are
not going over, there like, no,
you know I always, I
just always liked it.
I always liked trying new things and
pretending to be different people
and believe it or not, I'm very shy.
You wouldn't believe it now but and
certain situations I'm very shy.
And it was a way for me to
not be shy; strangely enough
and I just love it so much.
I do; yes ma'am, that, you honey.
>> Marina.
>> Octavia Spencer: Marina,
what's your question?
[ Inaudible ]
>> Octavia Spencer:
Ooh what's the, whoa,
what do we do when we can't hear?
Ah! Ok. What's your question honey?
Really loud like you're
yelling at your little brother.
>> How long did it take
you to write this book?
>> Octavia Spencer: How long did
it take me to write the books,
now that is a very,
very good question.
It took me to write the
first book, how old, is it;
we're going to play a
little guessing game.
How long do you think
it took me to write it?
>> Two years.
>> Octavia Spencer: Two
years, who thinks two years?
Who thinks two years?
Who thinks longer than two years?
One year? Two years.
Do I hear three years?
>> Four years.
>> Octavia Spencer: Raise,
raise your hand when I call
out a year raise your hand.
Three years, five months,
no, four years,
five years, six years, seven years?
>> One year.
>> Octavia Spencer: One year,
ok all in favor of one year.
Who wants to vote one year?
Ok, it took me seven years.
Because guys you have to write and
you have to rewrite and you have
to keep changing things because
the story changes and you want
to make it better and
better and better.
So seven years it took
me for the first one.
Yes, nope, you already
asked a question.
I'll come back to you.
There's a young lady right here,
right, you, with the dark hair
with the blue shirt, you, in
front of she had her hand raised
at the same time, you
honey, you, you, you.
[ Inaudible ]
>> Octavia Spencer: In front of, in
front of yellow shirt, I've, yeah,
you had your hand raised,
no I didn't, no I didn't,
it wasn't me, it wasn't me lady.
Ok anybody else who
hasn't asked a question
yet that would like
to ask a question.
Ok, I think you asked
a question right?
What's your name?
Ok what's your question babe?
[ Inaudible ]
>> Octavia Spencer: Which
one have I been in the long,
you guys are consumed
with this movie stuff.
The longest, a, well, that's
a, that's a tough question.
See, we took I did an action
movie in Prague which I was there
for five months in Prague and I, we,
but the Help I filmed
it in four months.
So I worked in Prague
longer than I did the Help,
but I have a bigger part in the Help
than I did in the one in Prague.
So it's a two part, two parter.
I'm sorry?
[ Inaudible ]
>> Octavia Spencer: Yes ma'am.
Ah! Ok.
>> My name is Sydney and
where did you go to school?
>> Octavia Spencer: Her name
is Sydney and where, very,
and that might be my
favorite question of the day.
I went to South Johnson Elementary;
then Highland Avenue Elementary,
then I went to Cloverdale
Junior High School,
Jefferson Davis High School and
then I went to Auburn University
at Montgomery and then
Auburn University in Auburn,
which were a lot of schools?
So what school do you attend?
>> [Inaudible]
>> Octavia Spencer: Say that again?
>> Roots Charter Public School.
>> Octavia Spencer: Roots Public
Charter School, very nice yes ma'am.
Wait, wait, wait, you
haven't asked a question.
>> How old [Inaudible],
how old are your kids?
>> Octavia Spencer: My
kids, these are my children.
I don't have children,
these are my children.
And I think Randy is twelve,
eleven going on twelve.
Pudge and DC are both eleven.
They're my kids.
So tell me what you think
of them when you meet them.
Pudge is really tall and thin.
He's not pudgy at all.
Ok, oh yes ma'am what's your name?
>> Leasia.
>> Octavia Spencer: Leasia,
what's your question?
[ Inaudible ]
>> Octavia Spencer: Out
of all of my movies,
which one did I like the most?
It's like asking a mom, which one
of your babies do you love the most?
I loved them all because
they all changed me in a way.
Every part that I get to do there's
a lot of research that you have
to do to figure out like let's say,
I was going to play you in a move,
I would have to figure out how you
start your day; why you say a line
that you would say it; why
you like your hair braided.
So you got to figure out all the,
everything about the character
and you go on this journey with
them and so for me I like learning.
Remember I told you guys
that I like to learn?
I like to learn about people too.
I love to learn about
people, most of all.
Because that's what
helps me in my work.
So the movie that I am most proud
of, I think you're all too old young
to see it, it's called
Fruitvale Station.
But the movie that changed how I
view the world and how I view myself
in the world and made me a very
positive person, was the Help.
So yeah. Anybody who hasn't
asked a question, we've got this,
oh yes sir, you haven't
asked a question.
What's your name?
>> My name is Danny.
>> Octavia Spencer: Ok Danny.
What's your question?
You forgot?
>> What job would you want other
than being an author or an actress?
>> Octavia Spencer:
That is a good one.
I would want to be an FBI agent.
What's funny about that?
All day I've been joking and
nobody laughs, and I say I want
to be an FBI agent
[Laughter]; you're so funny.
No, no I would actually.
Or a detective.
I like, like I say, I like to
know things and detectives,
see for me an being an
actor is being a detective
because you have to
figure things out.
It's like putting pieces
of a puzzle together right?
So I'm all, I'm very much a
detective in my real life.
I'm always detecting.
But an FBI agent guys,
it's the road.
Yes ma'am.
Oh! Ada, Ada.
>> Is this a series?
>> Octavia Spencer: Yes the
second book is coming out, March.
Yes who hasn't asked a question?
Anybody, anybody has a burning
question not about movies,
not about anything like movies.
>> We need to give Octavia a hand.
You did a wonderful job.
It was really.
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at LOC dot gov.